is it a split in the universe as was so
commonly described in sci-fi in sci-fi
yes this is exactly a leading way of
thinking about quantum mechanics that
you say okay there's an electron and
it's in a superposition of spinning
clockwise and counterclockwise but then
the fact is when you look at it and
measure its spin you never see both of
them you see one or the other and
there's a leading theory says that
that's because there is a world a
parallel universe where there's the
electrons spinning clockwise and you saw
it spinning clockwise and a separate
distinct Universe where the electron was
spinning counterclockwise and that's
what you saw in fact this is more or
less the straightforward prediction of
the equations that we've been lovingly
describing here and I wrote a whole
other book my previous book was called
something deeply hidden describing and
defending exactly that point of view so
I am someone who actually does think
that is really what happens not everyone
agrees yet